ce cri qui mode style autour de la table
si vous deviez partir un mois sur une
île déserte avec un des garçons ou une
femme à l'huile et bien sûr michel maire
en lui
[Applaudissements]
faut il inviter mairie jean-michel même
lui plaire aux patrons en cas
aujourd'hui c'est ça vous fait quoi
bah je suis assez ému je suis troublé
mais j'aimerais bien qu'ils aient une
suite parce que ça c'est des paroles
après il faut que non là bas si je vois
que vous regardez peu l'émission parce
que là vous avez mis le doigt dans un
truc mais c'est ce que séduire votre
corps tient mais qui va taper là vous
êtes pasdaran et amoureuse à tes années
sérieux ça oui je suis marié ou pas bien
sûr un très longtemps celle-ci savoir
qu'est ce cas ci ça veut stop et demi
c'est un peu le stopper si ce n est pas
parce qu il respecte l'homme et qu'elle
respecte la femme et respecte la fibre